last time we talked about bohmian
mechanics a possible alternative to
quantum mechanics one of the appeals of
bohmian mechanics is that we can always
at any time say that this is the
position of our particle on the other
hand with quantum mechanics the
superposition principle forces us to say
things like the particle is in many
different states at the same time with
bohmian mechanics it's as though reality
properly exists regardless of whether
we're measuring it or not or does it
today we're going to look at a
potentially big problem with bohmian
mechanics the issue is something called
contextual ax t let me explain it with
any sensible Theory you want measurement
to reveal a property that the particle
already had not create or change it I
should point out that under this
condition quantum mechanics is clearly
not sensible but from what we saw last
time it seems like bohmian mechanics is
so if you measure say the spin of a
particle in the Y direction and you find
it to be spin up in bohmian mechanics
you want to be able to say then that the
particle had spin up beforehand but what
about the case where there's more than
one way to measure the spin of a
particle another sensible sensibility
criteria is that different ways to
measure something should agree so both
those measurements should give the same
answer we'll call this non contextual ax
T because the result of the measurement
shouldn't depend on the experimental
context this is where the problem is
though in bohmian mechanics this doesn't
always happen so instead of always being
able to say statements like this
particle has spin up in the Y direction
you're instead reduced to saying things
like this particle has spin up in the Y
direction if you measure it this way but
spin down if you measure it another way
it's still perfectly deterministic
there's no randomness but it's just not
that nice this is what we call
contextual ax t
let me show you an example of this
happening this example is going to be
about the spin of an electron don't
panic if you've forgotten all about spin
I'm
they're going to use some very basic
facts about it if you want a refresher
on spin though you can go watch this
video about it first remember that every
electron has its pin pointing in one
particular direction however it's also
possible to measure the spin of an
electron in any direction and this is
where it gets weird whatever direction
you pick there are only two possible
values you can get which we call spin up
and spin down for reasons that you'll
see soon if you're feeling uncomfortable
about spin at this point feel free to
watch that video and ask me questions
back to spin though there's a pretty
standard way to measure the spin of a
particle it's called the stern-gerlach
machine you set it up to measure spin
along a certain axis let's say the y
axis then what happens is electrons go
through this passage I won't go into how
this works but if your particle happened
to be one that already had spin up in
the y axis it will get deflected up and
get measured around here if your
particle started with spin down in the Y
axis then it will get deflected down how
does bohmian mechanics explain this
remember that Imbaba mechanics there is
a quantum force that depends on the
wavefunction well spin is one of the
things that influence the wavefunction
so the quantum force takes spin into
account and then pushes the electron in
the correct directions to get these
cases of course most electrons have
their spin in other directions what
about if a bunch of electrons happen to
have their spin in the X direction which
is perpendicular to Y as we saw in the
spin video when you measure these
particles in the Y Direction half of
them will have spin up and half of them
will have spin down again bohmian
mechanics needs to explain this first we
need to deal with something there is no
real randomness in Fermi mechanics only
randomness from ignorance so we need to
be able to explain why half the
particles go one way and half the other
this is how it's done
let's say all the electrons set us
somewhere inside this little sphere but
we don't know exactly where inside if
one of these particles starts off in the
top half you can calculate by bohmian
mechanics that it will deflect up and
similarly for the bottom half giving
exactly the right result no issues so
far now let's look at sensibility
condition number one again we measure
that this particle starts here and has
spin up in the Y direction so our
condition tells us that it must have had
spin up in that direction all along
again this seems fairly innocuous the
problem is that there's another way to
measure the spin of that particular
particle why not set the stern-gerlach
machine to measure spin in the negative
y direction instead what should happen
well we've already decided that this
particle has spin up in the Y direction
so by the properties of spin it must
have spin down in the negative direction
sorry that's the last fact that I'll use
from that spin video so that means that
our particle has spin down in the
negative y direction so it's deflected
down now right not that's not what
bohmian mechanics says it still goes up
which forces us to conclude that it has
spin down in the Y direction and now we
see how our second sensibility condition
is broken if we measure the first way
our particle will look like it had spin
up but if we measure the second way it
will look like it had spin down notice
that I'm not saying bohmian mechanics
makes the wrong experimental prediction
because in the second case we also
expect that half the electrons deflect
up and half deflect down and that's
exactly what happens when your mechanics
can give you the right predictions on
any stern-gerlach experiment the issue
is much more subtle than that if we
can't say our particle has property X
without adding the proviso so long as
you measure it this way then what
property does the particle have before
anyone decides how to measure it I mean
this seems like a quantum mechanics
level philosophical problem
should we scrap bohmian mechanics and
look for some other better alternative
to quantum not so fast in fact it's
possible to prove that for any theory
that has sensibility condition number
one that experiments reveal pre-existing
properties then our second condition
that properties don't depend on the type
of experiment will always be broken at
least whenever you're talking about spin
in other words there are no completely
sensible theories there's a lot of hype
about this contextual 'ti but I'm not
sure how seriously we should take it you
see this issue doesn't come up at all
when we're talking about most variables
in bohmian mechanics like position
momentum and energy it's perfectly
legitimate to say that this particle has
this position regardless of how you
measure it the problem only comes when
you try and say statements like that
about spin and other similar variables
that's why some people say the theory
isn't broken only the way we think about
spin is they say
spin is not a real property of a
particle like position and momentum
instead it only comes into play in an
indirect way the spin affects the
wavefunction which affects the quantum
force which changes the direction of the
particle it doesn't make sense to say a
particle has spin up instead what you
mean is the particle experiences some
extra quantum force upwards because of
spin I'm pretty conflicted about this
and I'd love to hear your opinion about
all of this
does bohmian mechanics escape or is this
really the final blow for all sensible
alternatives to quantum mechanics I
don't know but I'd like to leave you
with one deep and meaningful thought
though spin is weird